[Musique]
bonjour à tous et merci de votre
fidélité à dimanche en politique sur
france 3 bourgogne six mois après les
élections législatives qui ont donné une
large majorité à emmanuel macron nous
ouvrons le débat ce dimanche matin le
nouveau monde annoncée par le président
de la république est-il en marche
y at il une évolution dans la façon de
faire la politique les réformes voulues
par emmanuel macron vont-elles porter
leurs fruits la vie des français at elle
déjà commencé à changer de débuter
bourguignons ont accepté d'en débattre
ce dimanche matin en direct sur france 3
fadila khattabi bonjour vous vous êtes
député la république en marge de la 3ème
circonscription de côte-d'or c'est votre
premier mandat à l'assemblée nationale
depuis juin dernier
rémi delattre bonjour vous êtes député
les républicains de la 2e
circonscription de côte-d'or et c'est
votre troisième mandat merci à tous les
deux d'avoir accepté de débattre
aujourd'hui vous qui nous regarde et
vous pouvez bien sûr commenter en direct
cette émission sur les réseaux sociaux
avec le hashtag dit mme paul bourgogne
vous en avez l'habitude alors pour
débuter ce débat j'ai envie de vous
demander à tous les deux comment vous
avez vécu c'est presque six mois de
mandat
alors pour vous faire dit la cata
biquettes nouvelle au palais bourbon et
comment ça se passe écoutez ça se passe
bien
c'est vrai que le rythme il est
relativement soutenu le président de la
république veut aller vite vite et bien
donc nous n'avons pas perdu de temps dès
cet été les premiers textes de loi ont
été mis sur la table et adoptez donc je
pense notamment sur la loi de la
moralisation de la vie publique ou
encore les ordonnances donc nous sommes
aller très très vite sur la loi travail
qu on dit que les nouveaux députés
notamment ceux de la majorité sont
épuisés fatigué alors d'abord est ce que
vous en faites partie est ce que vous
constatez une certaine fatigue chez vos
collègues
écoutez je crois que en tout cas un
titre personnel y compris d'ailleurs
pour mes collègues c'est un honneur de
pouvoir servir la france de pouvoir
servir les français
nous sommes tout à fait conscients des
enjeux il y a des attentes
nos compatriotes ont des attentes très
importante sur le plan de l'emploi sur
le plan de logement surtout de
l'éducation et donc nous sommes tout à
fait conscients que nous n'avons pas de
temps à perdre alors rémy de lattes vous
êtes député depuis 2007 vous avez été
dans la majorité dans l'opposition vous
connaissez bien le palais bourbon
comment vous avez vécu ces six mois
est-ce que ça a beaucoup changé
d'abord d'emblée je vais vous dire que
c'est plus confortable d'être dans la
majorité que dans l'opposition
tu vois ce si surprenant ça tient il ya
des gens que si c'est très confortable
dans l'opposition vous savez aussi bien
écouter
en tout cas je suis de ceux qui
aujourd'hui observe effectivement qui
s'est passé quelque chose d'important
derrière l'élection de emmanuel macron
qu' il ya une attente très forte des
français et qui a d'ailleurs justifié en
partie cette élection un renouvellement
d'image une volonté de réforme derrière
cinq années qui ont effectivement
paralysé qui ont cabossé j'ose le mot
qui ont cabossé la france et qui nous
ont placés dans une dans un
environnement sur le plan économique
social et politique désastreux et donc
il y avait une vraie attente des
français est aujourd'hui l'image
d'emmanuel macro une image de la
jeunesse mais maria jeu matières nobles
et de la politique moderne moderne j'ose
le mot fait qu' il ya une aussi une
mobilisation de l'opinion en faveur du
prix du président de la république mais
qui au niveau de l'organisation du
parlement particulier n'est pas aussi
évidente
qu'est-ce qui vous avez l'impression de
ne pas être quelque chose évidemment
persévérer est ce que le pouvoir du
parlement est un peu mis de côté au
classement vous avez des mots
complètement et on le voit aujourd'hui
avec des ordonnances travail
les ordonnances travail c'est un texte
qui était très attendu et et que nous
soutenons c'est pour dire que je suis
dans une dans une opposition tout à fait
objective vous vouliez pas d'ordonnancé
voulait pouvoir débattre mais
sereinement dans tous les articles
on sait que il ya urgence effectivement
à réformer au niveau du travail il n'y a
pas retiré d'emblée au parlement son
rôle de débats de propositions et je
pense qu'on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler mais je suis surpris dans ce
dans ce mandat de vous
alors que on instaure pas le débat au
sein de l'assemblée nationale parce que
le groupe la république en marche qui
était un groupe puissant avec plus 300
députés se trouve en réalité dans une
démarche et ma collègue fadila khattabi
le dit elle-même
il faut apprendre il faut observer et
c'est difficile aujourd'hui de
s'impliquer directement dans le débat et
on voit bien qu'elle est certaine cap à
l'organisation aux jo si le terme des
députés qui n'ont pas le droit de faire
ce que j'aime s'ils veulent vous munir
d'un mot et puis on voit poser les armes
possibles je voudrais déjà revenir sur
ce qu'a dit monsieur le député sur la
situation et l'héritage du président
hollande vous oubliez que vous avez fait
partie d'une majorité sous nicolas
sarkozy et que la situation était aussi
extrêmement difficile je l'avouer y
avait la crise
j'ai envie mais il n'avait pas pris non
plus les mesures adaptées à la situation
quand même qui était catastrophique donc
le président hollande j'ai envie de dire
qu'il a fait ce qu'il a pu avec
l'héritage aussi qu'il a eu donc je le
dis et concernant la caporalisation
alors vous avez un complet théorique et
que ces écoutes et il a fait monsieur le
député a fait aussi partie d'une
majorité très forte
il y avait aussi une majorité précédente
qui était aussi importante aujourd'hui
effectivement la république en marche
nous sommes 313 députés la république en
marche son compte effectivement le modem
donc un groupe important mais nous
travaillons ensemble nous débattons il
ya le travail en commission le travail
on maudit sion le travail dans
l'hémicycle nous débattons et nous
sommes absolument pas caporaliser alors
vous en parlait il ya un instant fadila
khattabi avec sa loi de moralisation de
la vie politique le gouvernement
d'edouard philippe a tenu à lever le
flou sur un certain nombre de pratiques
des élus parlementaires notamment avec
la suppression de l'emploi des membres
de leur famille une question est ce que
c'est suffisant pour que le nouveau
monde advienne le fameux nouveau monde
dont a parlé mais c'est les maquettes
cette loi était tout de même attendu
attendu surtout suite à l'élection
présidentielle et aux affaires qui ont
entaché la classe politique c'était
important
donc aujourd'hui oui cette loi fait en
sorte qu' aucun député ne peut désormais
embaucher un membre de sa famille un
conjoint son enfant donc c'était aussi
important il y a eu également la
surpression de la réserve parlementaire
qui bien sûr qu'elle rendait qu'elle
était utile pour certains projets dans
les territoires cetera il est mais je
n'en doute pas mais de quoi parlons nous
on parle de 140 150 millions d'euros
les associations à côte ce qui concerne
les associations
c'est un budget de 2 milliards donc
voilà sur la réserve parlementaire qui a
donné lieu à des débats intenses
on va dire même où le il compris au
sénat c'était important ce qui était
reproché c'est elle à la ventilation de
manière clientéliste et puis on nous
considérons effectivement qu'un député
il est là pour légiférer faire des lois
améliorer le quotidien de nos
concitoyens est pas pour distribuer une
enveloppe de manière clientéliste rémi
delattre l'ancien monde c'est un peu
vous hein c'est finalement ce que vous
reprochez emmanuel macron ce qui est
reproché aux partis traditionnels dont
les républicains
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que
l'ancienne façon de faire la politique
est révolu aujourd'hui où est-ce qu'on
est encore là dedans
la loi de moralisation aurait pu être
tout à fait un signe intéressant dans ce
sens là mais vous savez c'est pas le
nouveau monde et pas rêver avec la loi
de moralisation le quand même vous
rappelez entendu travail qu'on veut
quand même vous rappeler que la loi de
moralisation elle avait été exigée par
françois bayrou alors ministre garde des
sceaux quelques semaines plus tard et
quittait le gouvernement pour emploi
fictif
madame de sarnez ministre aussi quitte
le gouvernement
à cause des emplois fictifs monsieur
richard kit qui était ministre de
l'intérieur en référence khattabi appel
faisons confiance à la justice et
confiance quitte le gouvernement pour
devenir le patron du groupe en marche et
qui d'ailleurs espère bien aller encore
plus loin dans son parcours puisque on
dit qu'il pourrait devenir le président
de l'assemblée nationale à la faveur du
redoux
allemand qui avait souhaité le président
actuel qu'est ce que vous voulez dire
aux ja perd finalement on s'aperçoit que
j'ai des collègues de la deûle à la
france insoumise
certes c'est pas votre groupe gardner
logement hlm
on voit qu'il ya une collègue qui mord
un chauffeur de taxi
on voit deux collègues d'une autre
marche on voit qu'il ya un collègue du
groupe en marche qui donne des coups de
cache cache et pagaie on voit une
collègue du groupe en marche
il ne fait plus partie du malheur
canassons fédérateur fait des
prestations de visite de l'assemblée on
est trempés je veux dire c'est merci de
lattes vous exagérez
quand je pense que vous avez le pacte
est rompu je sais mais quand même on ne
peut pas on peut pas dire qu'on est dans
le nouveau monde dans ces conditions-là
fadila khattabi
je souhaitais c'est qu'au contraire on
arrête de stigmatiser des élus par la
réserve parlementaire vous savez il ya
deux jours j'étais à champagne sur
vingeanne où nous inaugurions une un
espace culturel et touristique dans une
ancienne halle de gare j'ai été très
fier d'avoir pu apporter une subvention
au travers de la réserve parlementaire
c'est pas moi d'ailleurs il ne s'est pas
le député non c'est déjà fait en sorte
que des fonds soient fléchi lundi la
cata bijoux et les siens de la tête
non mais c'est pas du clientélisme
j'ai donné sur sur les dix années de
mandat un billion 4eme là je ne dis pas
qu'on travaille n'a pas été bien fait
monsieur le député je ne dis pas cela
mais il s'avère que certains députés
certains élus distribuer cette cette
réserve de manière opaque
il aurait peut-être fallu revoir la
distribution de cette réserve
parlementaire
via le nom via une clause si l'on fait
de lui le désirons une telle somme
géré par une seule personne un homme et
c'est ça qui est élevé comme il le
souhaite finalement à discrétion
c'est choquant pour vous bah disons que
les français en tous les cas ne
comprennent pas qu'un député qui est là
pour faire des lois encore une fois
légiférer puisse tout seul décidé la
distribution d'un nom de fonds publics
c'est ça la réalité n'avait pas eu
l'occasion de
de gérer de la réserve parlementaire
vous n'étiez pas parlementaire gt r 10
ans avec une réserve parlementaire
chaque parlementaire disposait de 130
mille euros il qu'il peut faire
attribuer à tel ou tel projet dont l'une
d'une collectivité une commune comme le
thé de kobe il ya ces associations c'est
pas le député qui donne à tout ministère
de l'intérieur qui lui sa ministre de
l'intérieur qui étonne et messieurs du
lac et tout ça n'est pas au pack non
même si j'aurais transparence qui est
gelée plier tous les ans ce qui est
étrange ce qui est étrange c'est que
certains élus maires pour ne pas les
citer m'ont dit effectivement que cette
réserve était distribuée de manière
clientéliste pour ce pour certains ils
n'ont jamais vu la couleur d'un euro
alors qu'ils avaient eux aussi des des
projets on va faire tout l'émission joue
pas mais enfin tout mais ça donne
effectivement à des débats vifs
il est encore de la main sur l'élection
de christophe castaner à la tête de la
république en marche
fadila khattabi ça n'est pas forcément
peut-être le meilleur exemple de
renouvellement un proche du président un
seul candidat désigné coûté un score
quasi christophe castaner et franchement
moi je suis très contente que ce soit
christophe castaner qui soit la tête du
mouvement
quelqu'un qui est apprécié et apprécié
des marcheurs et des marcheuses apprécié
des parlementaires
quelqu'un qui est intelligent qui a
effectivement la confiance du président
et c'est un mouvement qui est jeune tout
est à faire
donc il est important aussi à la tête de
ce mouvement de mettre quelqu'un avec
une expérience avec
intelligence pour pouvoir structurer le
mouvement et choque pas non pas du tout
pas du tout et minutes moi je porte pas
de jugement sur sur la qualité de
l'homme qui de fait quelques grandes
personnalités aujourd'hui dans le
contexte politique mais ce qui me
surprend c'est que monsieur castaner a
été désigné par le chef de l'état et on
a dit aux marcheurs et marcheuses vous
voter pour monsieur castanet ramène v on
n'est quand même pas dans un dispositif
nouveau est allé voir prenez des changes
chez les républicains à cet égard c'est
un certain nicolas sarkozy tout le monde
était au gua drogba fillon pour 2 dvd
mais non je vous trouvez normal que le
chef du premier parti de la majorité
soit aussi ministre de la république
autres n'étaient pas et pendant ce temps
là on dit opposé pendant ce temps dit au
parlement
je ne vous ai pas beaucoup en tête vu
quand c'était nicolas sarkozy qui est
membre du parti
habillez vous parler du nouveau monde
voilà ce que cette histoire lui le dire
à l'histoire nous le doubs nous dira
effectivement aujourd'hui je considère
que le changement est en route qu'il ya
une nouvelle donne politique une
nouvelle classe politique fait de
personnes expérimentées les expériences
de la vie il y en a avec des talents
avec cette volonté effectivement de
faire réussir la france de faire réussir
tous les talents et on peut aujourd'hui
considérer que les choses ont changé
alors effectivement je termine juste si
vous le permettez
c'est vrai que les députés la république
en marche ne sont pas de vieux briscards
alors il n'ya pas toujours les corps il
n'y a pas voilà mais c'est celle qui
d'ailleurs est nécessaire et dissiper à
la majorité pour avoir l'ex bien sûr
mais il s'est fait de gens expérimentés
et des gens qui viennent de la société
civile parce que là aussi c'est la vraie
vie et donc c'est important aussi de
pouvoir les entendre et faire en sorte
de répondre aux attentes des français on
va avancer sur la méthode des manuels
macro et de sa majorité si vous le
voulez bien alors fer de lance de son
ambition politique la réforme par
ordonnance du code du travail conduite
par muriel pénicaud a consacré une
meilleure flexibilité pour les
entreprises notamment pour les pme au
delà de la réforme elle même
méthode la concertation comptant quelque
sorte empêcher une explosion sociale les
syndicats divisés et la gauche n'ont pas
réussi à mobiliser contre cette loi qui
est finalement passé presque comme une
lettre à la poste alors fadila khattabi
est ce que c'est ça la méthode macron je
crois que le président l'a annoncé
pendant la campagne présidentielle il a
dit ce qu'il allait faire il fait ce
qu'il dit il a dit effectivement qu'il
fallait libérer les énergies libérer
l'initiative la crémation soutenir le
développement économique
et ça passe effectivement par cette loi
sur le renforcement du dialogue social
donc c'est aussi important et il ya un
deuxième volet parce que c'est un
package et un deuxième volet à savoir
donc la protection des actifs j'aurais
qu'elle vaut travaillant sur laquelle
nous travaillons actuellement à savoir
la réforme de la formation
professionnelle de l'apprentissage
également effectivement le droit au
chômage qui va aussi être réformé donc
voilà c'est un package de caen quand on
paye à la mobilisation qu'il ya eu
contre la loi très conneries on aurait
pu imaginer le même petit civilisation
et ça n'a bizarrement pas eu lieu alors
il ya urgence et rendre hommage à la
ministre madame pénicaud vraiment une
femme intelligente et qui s'est
effectivement pour le coup prôné le
dialogue social il ya eu quand même à
peu près 70 réunions plus de 300 heures
de réunion donc le dialogue des
religions celle lesarge montré elle nous
a également rencontré on a auditionné
plusieurs fois aussi la ministre pour
savoir effectivement qu'elle était quels
étaient les lignes directrices et c'est
donc tout avait été mis sur la table
discuter et effectivement c'est c'est un
c'était une réussite donc ce volet là
est une première étape est la deuxième
étape étape ça va être effectivement la
réforme de la formation de lattes la
réforme du code du travail celle que
finalement vous à droite vous auriez
tant aimé faire et que vous n'avez
jamais réussi à faire elle passe comme
une lettre à la poste
alors c'est un texte qui d'ailleurs nous
a assez rapprochés parce que c'était de
l'essentiel de ce texte était dans le
programme que nous avons défendues
des élections présidentielle et
législatives on sait bien que pour
lutter contre le chômage il faut
apporter de la souplesse dans dans
l'entreprise
il faut faciliter effectivement le
recrutement il faut aussi défendre les
travailleurs et ça c'est un point sur
lequel on s'est retrouvé des uns et des
autres qui fait que d'ailleurs j'ai j'ai
comme la plupart des membres du groupe
l'est républicain
bien sûr suivi ce dossier mais aussi
soutenu sur la méthode vous avez aussi
un militant dans la rue dans votre il ya
quelque chose qui me gêne dans la
méthode c'est joli dit tout à l'heure le
fait qu'on ait eu recours aux
ordonnances
donc on peut penser qu'on aurait pu
installer un débat autour du travail
serait moi j'entends les entreprises
aujourd'hui nous dire des artisans de
dire l'ubs et risation c'est un vrai
souci là de tout ce qui est robotisation
aujourd'hui qui laisse planer
effectivement de grandes incertitudes
sur l'emploi demain c'est aussi des des
sujets sur lequel on aurait besoin
effectivement de de pouvoir s'exprimer
de se projeter dans l'avenir
est ce que vous comprenez la méthode qui
consiste à nier que c'est un sujet que
je suis débattre au sein au sein de
l'assemblée monsieur ne voulait pas dire
qu'ils ont pris dans l'immortel
il faut rythme derrière moi ce genre les
choses qu'on est aujourd'hui dans
l'incantation n'ont pas dû ça suffira
pas du tout est vraiment l'incantation
monsieur de la tournée vraiment dans
l'action et on répond vraiment aux
attentes faut qu'on aille plus loin des
concitoyens moi je rencontre des chefs
d'entreprise
les présidents de branche les
consulaires tous nous disent vous aller
dans le bon sens
il faut continuer et il ya ce deuxième
volet qui est très important qui va être
la protection des salariés la protection
des actifs parce que il faut aussi
répondre aux attentes des demandeurs
d'emploi on a connu que le chômage de
masse ont fait partie presque de la même
génération
depuis les années 80 donc nous n'avons
connu que le chômage de masse donc il
est important effectivement de relancer
aussi les investissements dans les
ressources humaines
or aujourd'hui ce n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui sur 100 euros dépensés dans
la formation professionnelle
seuls 15 euros
vont aux demandeurs d'emploi là aussi il
ya une vraie injustice sociale ya une
vraie inégalité donc ça va être la
deuxième phase à la claque sur laquelle
il va falloir travailler effectivement
se concerter négocier c'est très
important qui est attendue donc c'est
une rebond des reventes îles à sion des
fonds de la formation et on a pris
beaucoup de retard au niveau du chômage
est bien que vous ayez été à l'époque
vous aviez soutenu ce niveau la majorité
des cinq dernières années on a on a pris
du retard et n'a pas aujourd'hui et si
je suis aujourd'hui mais fait-on d'une
conjoncture qui est plus favorable
on devrait avoir effectivement le taux
de croissance de l'ordre de 1,8 pour
cent
c'est une aubaine qu'il faut absolument
utiliser tout pour accompagner
l'entreprise dans sa redynamisation
c'est ce que les clients internes de
reconduire aa1 plein emploi ce que nous
faisons ce que les pays voisins sur
l'autre a de mieux réussir que nous mais
non c'est ce qui c'est que nous nous
posions ces questions il faut qu'on
aille vraiment avec détermination
je suis prêt personnellement et je sais
que c'est l'avis des républicains
je suis prêt à aller dans ce sens pour
pour accompagner pour favoriser cette
cette mutation qui doit s'organiser
autour du travail dans la moderne bien
sûr parce que les comme vous l'avez dit
la protection des salariés des salariés
et des demandeurs d'emploi j'allais dire
des actifs de manière générale au delà
de la méthode
au delà de cette question de la loi
travail et des ordonnances qui
l'accompagnait j'ai envie de vous poser
à tous les deux la même question quelles
sont les réformes qui vous ont marqué en
bien ou en mal évidemment positive ou
négative de ces six derniers mois de
travail parlementaire fadila khattabi si
vous deviez retenir une ou deux réformes
qui vous tiennent à coeur lesquels
passer cette loi
cette loi qui est très importante vous
savez les français aujourd'hui ils n'ont
que une priorité vraiment très important
quand je suis sur le terrain c'est
l'emploi l'emploi alors les personnes
nous interpelle nous disent l'emploi
pour mon fils pour ma fille pour ma
petite fille c'est l'emploi et je le
quinquennat d'emmanuel macron sera jugé
sur la réussite ou pas sur le plan de la
régression du land très important mais
je crois que emmanuel macron il est
conscient
françois hollande a perdu deux ans sur
le quinquennat il était à l'origine
aussi ceci explique cette forme de
précipitation sinon c'est important
c'est important d'aller vite il n'y a
pas de temps à perdre
nous devons effectivement redonner une
vraie perspective d'avenir à la france
et à nos concitoyens nous avons
suffisamment perdu de temps donc il ya
eu le cce en 2014 qui commence à donner
certains fruits il faut aller beaucoup
plus loin et beaucoup plus vite je le
dis mais en même temps je le dis pour le
coup en même temps il va falloir
vraiment travaillé sur la protection des
actifs
rémi delattre qu'est ce que vous retenez
de ses six mois en terme de réformes
faites ou en train d'être fait
on voit l'intention de bonnes intentions
mais on voit aussi que l'on va pas
jusqu'au bout du chemin et en
particulier la loi de finances que nous
discutons actuellement qui a été voté en
1ère nature et est un être un élément
déterminant
on voit qu'il ya effectivement des
choses tout à fait positive qui vont
dans le par exemple le prélèvement
forfaitaire unique le jour de carence
dans la fonction publique que monsieur
hollande la majorité que vous souteniez
à l'époque avait avait abandonné et que
que nous remettons bas globalement une
baisse des impôts qui est qui a en tout
cas annoncés et qui donne fn n'est pas
tout à fait vérifier complètement en
tout cas et notamment vous parlez de la
pérennisation du cicr on perd 1% quand
même temps passant on passe de 7%
et ben voilà on est maintenant assez
pressant aux gratte on rabote un petit
peu en même temps qu'on prend des
mesures mais parce qu'on a de la loi de
sécurité intérieure dhs et qu'il la
sécurité la sécurité intérieure là aussi
ça c'est un signe que le président
aurait dû donner et au où le sang
frileuse sur sur cette dimension
moi j'ai toujours voté les lois de
sécurité j'ai dû revoter
sauf que c'est la loi qui est que donc
la sortie d'état d'urgence de emmanuel
macron et de gérard collomb ne va pas
dans le bon sens c'est pas bon signe que
l'on donne donc que l'on sorte de l'état
d'urgence a nécessité un peu c'est
nécessaire mais sortir de l'état
d'urgence
à condition de garantir la sécurité pour
nous consiste à partir du helmand où la
loi ne va pas assez loin
on retire des moyens pas considérable
pour garantir de sécurité on a retiré
malgré cela on aurait dû poser certaines
questions sur lesquelles les
républicains de nous sommes vraiment
positionné en particulier qu'est ce que
l'on fera des français qui vont revenir
de série qu'elle sort quelques quelle
sera la position de la france en la
matière est ce qu est ce que c est ce qu
on n'est pas en train de faire marche
arrière
notamment sur les moyens qui étaient
donnés aux forces de sécurité à la
justice aussi par exemple pour assurer
les perquisitions les contrôles de
schengen rémy des budgets au niveau de
la défense nommé les moyens les moyens
sont là ils sont plus dans la loi 2
c'était important quand même sortir
pourquoi il va s'en sortir de l'état
d'urgence en terme d'image 2d
internationale sur le plan international
c'est pas bon on voit aujourd'hui avec
le brésil qu'il y a kylie a
effectivement des de nombreuses
entreprises qui regarde du côté de
bonnes berlin ou qui regardent du côté
de la france parce qu'elle souhaite
effectivement revenir au sein de
l'europe de l'union européenne donc moi
je autant la faire je préfère que les
entreprises ces startups viennent
s'installer en france aujourd'hui c'est
aussi important mais quand vous avez le
terme état d'urgence
les chefs d'entreprise qui veulent
investir dans notre pays a découragé ça
décourage ils ont peur donc c'est
important mais on avait dans les mains
des modélisations l'état une obligation
c'est de là je vous ai pas un terreau
plus tout à l'heure vous narrer la
sécurité loi qui permet d'interrompre ce
que j'aimerais qu'on aborde le thème on
arrive vraiment à la fin de cette
émission que vous parliez tout à l'heure
de loi de finances c'est la politique
budgétaire et fiscale abaissement de
l'impôt sur les sociétés à 25%
suppression progressive de la taxe
d'habitation passage de l' isf ali fille
autant de mesures sur lesquelles l'état
compte pour les quais sur lesquels
l'état oui compte pour booster
l'économie alors est ce que c'est une
politique de droite qui est menée
emmanuel macron je pose la question à
monsieur de la d'abord il vous a pas
échappé que
en une minute après il vous a pas
échappé que le premier ministre est issu
des rangs des républicains et qu'il a
une culture de droite donc series et sa
prise de regarder les prix alors le
président sur certains aspects oui je
les 17 alors je vote certains textes
par contre on va pas jusqu'au bout des
choses je les dis je dédie sur les
signes qui ont été donnés notamment de
baisses de la fiscalité
c'était une bonne mesure on supprime
l'isf
c'est une bonne mesure movac au milieu
du chemin on continua à taxer le
patrimoine
paris a aussi dit gillot veut dire on
augmente la cg symphonie tout à fait
contre-productif ont répondu on est en
train de charger ou on est en train de
charger en particulier les retraités pas
du tout ce n'est pas du bon madame
kasubi non mais le choix ils sont soit
et que son épouse gamineries sur le go 3
millions d'euros
c'est la vision à la fin on line up à
792 euros de plus ou très bien de la vie
donc je laisserais mon acabit non on n'a
plus le temps est enfermée là rien faire
de la politique c'est aussi faire des
choix on nous a laissés faire des choix
je suis désolé vous parliez d'une
politique de droite mais quand on
augmente le minimum vieillesse 200 euros
donc sur trois ans 30 et quelques trente
et quelques euros sur trois ans quand on
augmente effectivement l'allocation
d'adulte handicapé c'est de droite
d on a fait un effort sans fil
considérable considérable quand on fait
quand on augmente les aides pour les
familles monoparentales pour les gardes
d'enfants
beaucoup de femmes élèvent seules leurs
enfants ces deux droits sillage de
jacques attali
merci à tous les deux d'avoir participé
à l'émission d'avoir accepté de débattre
ce matin dans un instant le point sur
l'actualité régionale puis la partie
nationale de dimanche en politique avec
francis letellier qui reçoivent la
ministre chargé des affaires européennes
ben dimanche
[Musique]